ciao ragazzi bentornato in una puntata
di cucina buttata oggi è una puntata
speciale perché abbiamo uno sponsor e
ogni volta che un brand sposa cucina
buttata noi non possiamo che essere
felice ecco perché ringrazio
personalmente ore o per aver deciso di
farci fare un giochetto che mi segue su
instagram già lo sa a casa arrivato un
enorme box pieno di ingredienti con i
quali dovrò fare una ricetta una ricetta
di un dolce che per me e treni preferiti
e la cosa bella è che mi piace in tutti
i modi alla banana alle fragole al latte
al caffè insomma potete farci quello che
volete colpire a misure questa ricetta
avrò bisogno di un alleato in cucina un
amico che mi aiuti e so che molti di voi
si aspettano una sfida tranne due una
sfida che determini chi sia
lo chef più bravo davanti ai fornelli
beh beh beh non è questo di giorno oggi
avrò come alleato confidente sostenitore
compagno di avventura c'è un pazzo ma
che ne che devo fare
dobbiamo cucinare quindi faccio qualcosa
di cucina se mi sbaglio
ok ok tu fai caffè l'ultima volta
esplosa la cucina
allora lo faceva il caffè che mio figlio
è meglio prima di cominciare col video
però dovremo fare una cosa che ci
ricordiamo di fare sempre all'inizio di
ogni ricetta quella di indossare il
grembiule e quindi siamo pronti non ce
ne sono già a me come non detto iniziamo
con gli ingredienti per fare il tiramisù
colore o avremo bisogno di una
tazzulella di caffè 120 g di zucchero
cacao amaro in polvere 500 grammi di
mascarpone 4 goufan fragole o frutti
rossi
altrimenti di torres ma soprattutto ora
oddio no niente costo di a me dovrebbe
più cielo dire dei commenti facciamo una
una sim ispirata alla moda vista anche
il fascino proviamo allora fateci sapere
ragazzi secondo voi effetto tubino della
serie rambo effetto cintura stile impero
morbido a me sembra come se avessi seni
ne devi andare a stringere no no voglio
i semi per prima cosa gianni bisogna
fare il caffè
io sono bravo a far caffè però con lo
fai uno schifo allora ti posso dire
secondo me io ho imparato per 4 persone
sulla moto ma è normale quindi portare
del caffè attore è normale ma guarda che
il casino ora capisco perché gianmarco
ogni volta che fai un caffè mi distrugge
tutto scusa ma non ce l'hai detto che
bisogna mettere una montagna beh quello
è una collinetta e stringi bene mi
raccomando non sapremo mai più fuoco
mi devi far fare qualcosa io non sono
uno sguattero di seconda ma ok fai anche
questa caffettiera bryce e giammarco
proprio quello che ci serviva questa è
una ricetta di una semplicità ab star
male infatti se la farete anche voi
ragazzi vi supplico tagga temi su
instagram
soprattutto se come anche altri stanno
facendo questa roba mettete hashtag
tingu il bus sfondiamo tutti gli altri
che stanno facendo e ricette facciamo
vedere se diamo l'algoritmo sfondiamo
l'algoritmo perché altre persone sta
facendo altre ricette capito avverrà ci
sono dei difetti thor che non li
chiamerei competitor delle minacce delle
minacce ragazzi dobbiamo per forza
portarla a casa
ci preme c'è per forza ma non che hanno
vinto di poco
no no no stracciati a mani basse questo
ruolo che ferrico non puoi farti non
come la rende tornerà per metterle in no
questo qui per voi intingere tutti
quanti biscotti
ma vai a gianmarco fallo sul lavandino
giocato così il cappello fa ragazzini
fra queste ricette di scarico sul sito
ci sta anche la cheesecake la crostata
oreo sane al cioccolato ma qual è il
cervello che non funziona scusa proprio
quello e fece cane accenna tv in bustina
nel suo miss lauder il mondo nel
frattempo io procedere all'apertura dei
biscotti
io mi sto diventando c'è troppa
attenzione all'interno di questa non
trovi gianmarco guglielmo c'è solo un
modo c'è solo un modo per superare i
conventi quale un po di mare o mancante
che vuol dire ricollocamento hai bisogno
di un po di nettare forse ha bisogno di
phil che mia moglie un'ambulanza abbiamo
subito che so un infermiere il mio caffè
prodotto prima del tuo quando un altro
milano servono della ricetta fermo dove
depositiamo il caffè qua allora no mai
zuccato andiamo a mettere il caffè in
questa zuppiera guglielmo si sta
affondando di oreo quindi devo mandarlo
avanti a questa ricetta mammamia
gianmarco che che movimento di pozzo
fanno un altro al vuol far vedere che
non ti fermano un lampo e far vedere
come si versa veramente il caffè quel
brutto ma vi si sfondati cioè questo qui
il pacco da che balla veramente la bocca
impastata da inizio ricettiva procediamo
abbiamo qui non solo appello abbiamo
fatto riposare un pochino quindi adesso
la temperatura è perfetta non annullerà
trap e biscotti passiamo immergerli
nella top ten in a san marco non voglio
che faccia tu la crema
davvero
[Musica]
è la prima volta per me che tendi unasco
del cuscino piatti salati ma non ho mai
fatto un dolce in vitamina per farti
capire perché capisci vi ho già capito
proprio marco di pre 4 uova non sta
accadendo niente ragazzi e di co2 di
riprenderlo ma non basta per la ricetta
tanti marchi ce stanno ancora quindi poi
potrei aggiungere zucchero
no se i frutti ed è qui che tremori ma
vai con la mano e poi attivi la frusta
la mano cioè prima di quello sopra cioè
il dito sbagliato e quello sopra bene
quando la mia vita del maestro a questa
nostra
bravo bravissimo come dicevi prima un
buon lavoro vero è il ragazzo di film ai
sogni che ha detto io non tigre
mamma mia la mia prima crepa che in
realtà è uno zabaione molto molto
domestico e raffazzonato mi verrebbe da
dire ma la tua prima crema aggiunge il
mascarpone e lavorano come accarezzarsi
tuo figlio come si accarezza si pullino
allora soca fuda senza paura tutti e 500
i grammi
ma se cartone ed era importantissimo in
cucina ma solo un pasticcere e
pasticcione mia sorella è una pasticcera
potrei avere nel dna quello che non sa
guglielmo beh oddio io e guidando si
chiama totalmente diversi ed entrambi
sappiamo chi è la pecora nera ecco la
prima mai detto come burdaux cosa volete
dire dalla mia crema
rispettate ci dobbiamo i biscotti enrico
fermati whitman tappo non vorresti
provarlo se ce la giochiamo aida
buttiamo lei giu 59 123456789 vabbè
quindi lui è fuori
vi dico subito che mai sia fondamentale
momento della vita inzuppare biscotti è
questo qui il momento nel quale uno può
rovinare o consacrano una ricetta perché
dipende tutto da quanto tu che ami
ammollo un biscotto troppo secco che
cosa succederà vi risulterà stopposo con
la crema un biscotto troppo umido
risulterà spappolo zoe ma a me e non
avverto trucchetto fondamentale che mi è
stato insegnato da una professionista
del tiramisù prendere il biscotto caffè
freddo oa temperatura ambiente e fare la
seguente cosa biscotto 123 di altri e
piazzate guardando anche un po
l'infinito 123 momento fondamentale
omerico sun
paro paro paro sodo se ci darete una
mano ragazzi passiamo a questo punto al
secondo strato gianni tu hai capito la
tecnica perfettamente procedo 3 perché
con così tanta foga lo zio come se fosse
un relitto da recuperare
aiutami non ho fatto niente 123 ora
parla qui quattro ore in frigorifero
molto molto bello gianni adesso è
arrivato il momento artistico esatto che
rasenta intanto di fare una spolverata
di cacao non certo facile cacao quando
si tratterà di mettere gli ora è sopra i
frutti potrebbe essere pericoloso
[Musica]
e quando si torna il cerchio significa
che il lavoro è stato fatto bene e il
risultato è questo spero che vi piaccia
fatemi sapere qui sotto se le mie doti
di decoratore incontrano i vostri gusti
era il momento di passare all'assaggio
guardatemi queste monoporzioni io già
marco non solo che abbiamo creato una
torta che di per sé un'installazione
d'arte è una scultura contemporanea il
cui nome è se potrei permettermelo
bellezza devo dire che è un piatto
indicante solitamente il tiramisù non è
che sia questa bellezza da guardare devo
dire che l'unione di jean marc guglielmo
non pensavo potesse tira fuori un piatto
simile io vorrei anche farvi notare che
la singola porzione a una ricercatezza
infatti si chiama ricerca tesa e io da
non amante lo trovo comunque gradevole a
essere bello è bello bravi non va avere
dato una lira e allo stesso tempo con
questo ribes è un rivers questo mi dà un
pochino più di classe il biscotto e i
frutti gli danno maggiore vivacità
questo piatto
ho fatto anche io vi siete meritati 18
questo è tutto un cappello introduttivo
per dirvi che ti do i do un 7 7bello
carino 7 più odore cacao e cacao e cacao
cacao
non può il caffè e allora è buono sento
più pacato l'odore da dolce al
cioccolato
mi aspettavo qualcosa in più per un
tiramisù che in realtà poi sabic a caldo
quindi di nell'odore voto 7
certo e mezzo sei e mezzo
adesso il sapore quello che mi interessa
sinceramente una consistenza da tiramisù
del biscotto è perfetto s
il biscotto è perfetto 123 è il giusto
equilibrio tra morbido non fradicio non
troppo secco non troppo duro né troppo
morbido una roba clamorosa anzi da un
altro biscotto dalla regia la crema ed
una perfetta il per fessi sposa
benissimo e non sono un grande fan del
caffè io non sono un amante dei dolci
come alcuni sapranno però mi piace il
caffè il ribes pazzesco e mi piacciono
questi cosi rossi il ribes da quella
nota acidula che ci sa benissimo 9 meno
sette e mezzo otto e mezzo il biscotto
figura di quanto sei disposto a pagare
7 euro cioè comunque dobbiamo pagare la
forza lavoro mia e di gianmarco mi sono
fatto da solo 5 euro oppure creando
perché solo uno dei due cuochi per un
tiramisù monoporzione 5 euro per questo
qualcosina in più la darà i bravi
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video ringraziamo ancora oreo per
avere sponsorizzato questa puntata di
cucina è buttata mi raccomando negli
infobox trovate il link al loro sito per
scoprire questa ricetta abbiamo fatto
insieme un botto di altre come sempre vi
invito a iscrivervi a questo canale
attivare le notifiche ma soprattutto
mettere un bel pollice in su per aver
visto finalmente gianmarco all'opera in
cucina noi ci vediamo come sempre
giovedì prossimo alle 12 con un nuovo
video
ciao
battute più belli secondo mè è merito
tuo
grazie alla prossima alla prossima